Dr. Crocker selected three unassembled IKEA
STEFAN chairs, as well as two assembly manuals,
for experimentation.
First, one unassembled chair was placed inside
on "Fine," without a manual.
The output produced was an assembled chair,
the pieces put together at random.
Next, an unassembled chair was placed on the
same setting, along with its assembly manual.
The output produced was an assembled chair,
with the front and back legs swapped, and
damage to its seat as if someone had hit it
with a hammer in frustration.
For the final trial, Dr. Crocker placed an
unassembled chair, a manual, and a note reading
"You can do it!"
inside, on the setting "Very Fine."
The Clockworks produced not a chair, but a
60cm wooden automaton with an obsessive enthusiasm
for assembling furniture, though it was not
especially good at it.